today on the matt wells show nfl head
coach john gruden has been forced to
resign after the media published his
private emails containing quote vulgar
language meanwhile the nfl still employs
domestic abusers rapists drug addicts
but none of those crimes are as bad as
thought crimes apparently also southwest
cancellations continue as the ceo of the
company continues to deny that it has
anything at all to do with a vaccine
mandate and california always on the
forefront of the culture of death passes
a bill making it easier for people to
kill themselves all of that plus our
daily cancellation and more today at the
matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
i think this is pretty simple if you
have people in your life who rely on you
as i do as so many of us do then you
really need to have life insurance if
you don't have life insurance yet
you know you're going to wait and wait
until it's too late that's that's the
tragedy of it
and why do that go to policy genius and
they can make it so easy for you by
comparing quotes from over a dozen top
insurers all in one place why compare
well you could save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius you could save 300 or more
per year on life insurance by using
policy genius to compare policies the
license experts apology genius work for
you not the insurance company so you can
trust them to help you navigate the step
uh every step of the shopping and buying
process they have no ulterior motive
they're just trying to make it easier
and more affordable for you that kind of
service has earned policy genius
thousands of five-star reviews across
trustpilot and google the this um
and eligible applicants can get covered
in as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirement
for a simple phone call so many reasons
to go to policy genius so go there now
policygenius.com to get started right
now policy genius when it comes to
insurance it's nice to get it right so a
few days ago john gruden the now former
head coach of the las vegas raiders in
the nfl
became the subject of intense scrutiny
when it was revealed in a stunning
report from the wall street journal that
he had sent an email uh 10 years ago
making fun of someone's big lips
the recipient of the email bruce allen
then president of the then redskins was
not the target of the lips comment
gruden was referring to a third
guy demoris smith who's the executive
director of the nfl players association
does demoris smith actually have big
lips well if you were to compare
smith's lip circumference to the
national average for his height and
weight class you'd probably discover
that gruden's claim was statistically
correct
i imagine that my own lips would be on
the north end of average as well but the
difference
is that i am white and demoris smith is
black
it would be at worst a childish insult
to make that kind of physical
observation about a white man
but if in reference to a black man it is
an act of jaw-dropping racism that's the
rule anyway even if it doesn't make the
slightest bit of sense at all
and this was just the beginning of
gruden's troubles the public became
aware of lipgate because the nfl has
been combing through 650 000 emails in
connection with an investigation into
misconduct in the washington football
team organization gruden was never a
member of the washington football team
organization he was never accused of
misconduct um he wasn't even an employee
of the nfl when the allegedly racist
email was sent
but it was caught up in the dragnet
why was it released
out of the over half a million emails
the league has reviewed why was the
spotlight shown on this one
sent by a guy who was not being
investigated and who again wasn't an nfl
employee at the time
why
well that question has yet to be
answered mostly because it has yet to be
asked by the media
and it wouldn't exactly be a tin foil
hat conspiracy theory to suggest that
perhaps gruden's team the raiders have
something to do with with this with
these emails coming out
they coaxed gruden out of the espn
analyst booth in 2018 with a ludicrous
10-year 100 million dollar coaching
contract
emails aside gruden has not come close
to justifying that payday it's arguable
whether whether any coach could but in
his case in three years with the team
he's yet to finish with a winning record
and they're paying him 100 million
dollars
is this email scandal just a way for the
raiders to get out from under the
financially suicidal agreement they
signed with him
well i don't know we're left to
speculate
whoever is behind it and whatever their
reason
the goal's pretty clear
destroy john gruden
and it wouldn't be hard to accomplish
that objective aided by a media ever
eager to knock a white man off his perch
but the final nail in the coffin came
last night with a new york times report
detailing more
quote offensive emails sent by gruden to
allen during gruden's tenure as a sports
commentator so between 2011 2018 as the
time times reveals
gruden penned several vulgar emails
becoming no doubt the first person
affiliated with professional football to
ever use salty language gruden called
the nfl commissioner roger goodell in
one email an anti-gay slur and also a
quote clueless anti-football p word
now the latter characterization of the
widely hated goudel can also be heard
nearly verbatim on any given sunday in
any sports bar in the country
he blasted the commissioner for
pressuring the rams to draft michael sam
a few years ago who was the first openly
gay football player
and gruden called sam quote queer
now the word queer is used by gay people
themselves it's what the cue in lgbtq
stands for but as we've learned the
offensiveness of the term depends
entirely on what identity group the
person using it belongs to
the time says that gruden also called
for players who protest the anthem to be
fired
which is another sentiment that you can
hear in any sports bar in the country or
in millions of homes or almost anywhere
else
it's how most people feel about it
and there are more shocking disclosures
here's more from the new york times they
say gruden exchanged emails with alan
and other men that included photos of
women wearing only bikini bottoms
there's no indication that this was uh
there's no indication by the way that
this was a revenge porn situation
or that he was sharing pictures that had
been taken without consent
so that's that's an important point
though it also says uh quote privately
alan and gruden appeared to have few
boundaries in expressing homophobic and
transphobic language in one email gruden
crudely asked alan to tell brian glazier
whose family owns the tampa bay
buccaneers where gruden coached in 2008
2008 to perform oral sex on him allen
said glazier would take you up on that
offer
alan gruden also mocked caitlyn jenner
who received an award from espn in 2015
after quote unquote she transitioned
in an email from 2015 allen and gruden
criticized a congressional bill that
aimed to force the washington franchise
to change its name which the team
stopped using last year
okay so the takeaway from all this is
that john gruden
is about as crass and vulgar as
literally every man who has ever coached
or played football and who isn't named
tim tebow
he also has opinions about anthem
protests about caitlyn jenner about
goodell's leadership of the nfl
that are shared by tens of millions of
ordinary people
in spite of that or maybe really because
of it
gruden was still forced to resign late
last night so he's gone
and with him gone
nfl locker rooms will now be almost
entirely free of pg-13 language
we just need you know every other player
and coach to resign as well so one down
2 000 to go
and then locker rooms will be a place of
only g-rated language
and gentlemanly decorum
speaking of those other people
collecting paychecks from the nfl
it should be noted that among them
you'll find tampa bay buccaneers
cornerback richard sherman who was
arrested for domestic violence this past
summer
also also a houston texans quarterback
deshaun watson
who has been accused of sexual assault
by over 20 women 20. actually i think
it's like 23 to count this up to now
also you'll find bucks wide receiver um
uh antonio brown who's been accused of
violence against women on multiple
occasions also settled a sexual assault
lawsuit this past spring
and kansas city chief's wide receiver
tyree kill who pled guilty to punching
and choking his pregnant girlfriend
i could go on
indeed the nfl is now and has
historically been
filled with violent criminals
the difference between gruden's actions
and that of tyreek hill or any of the
other members of the nfl's nfl's
all-convict squad
is that gruden's behavior was victimless
okay these were private conversations
through email
between men who clearly were not
offended by the sort of jokes being told
in language being used
nobody was harmed in the writing of the
emails
nobody's feelings were even hurt
because nobody else knew about it these
were private conversations
the same cannot be said of tyrek hill's
battered girlfriend
or any of the 20 plus women that desean
watson has
allegedly assaulted
but in our terminally confused culture
and country
violent crimes do not weigh nearly as
heavy as thought crimes
because that's what this is
this is the policing of thought crimes
gruden harmed no one
he reserved his crass jocularity for
private communications between friends
there is no reason
why we ought to have been told what he
said
and now that we have been told
there's no reason to be offended
because the conversations didn't concern
us
and we were not intended they were not
intended for our eyes or ears
but all that's beside the point for the
canceled culture
you know if the cancel mob could develop
the technology to read your mind
they would not hesitate to do it
and they would not hesitate to summarily
cancel you for things you don't even say
out loud
i mean after all canceling someone for a
private email exchange is only one small
step away from canceling them for
private thoughts
in fact it's not really a step away at
all the two are not removed
it is the thought that's being
prosecuted by the pitchfork mob tribunal
here
the fact that many of the thoughts
gruden shared and some of the words he
used are common among ordinary people
is precisely the point
the nfl higher ups you know they may
have had their own self-serving profit
motivated reasons for throwing him to
the wolves
but for the wolves themselves
tearing him apart is meant to be a
message to the onlookers
and the message is stop thinking this
way or you're next
and yet it still isn't quite as simple
as that
because not all thought crimes are
prosecuted the same
the nfl may have strapped gruden to a
donkey and exiled him to the hinterlands
but uh they'll still be paying millions
of dollars for a super bowl half-time
show this february featuring the likes
of eminem dr dre and snoop dogg all of
whom have used all of the words gruden
used and then some in dozens of hit
songs
that were released to the public
a few of which will actually be
performed during that broadcast
that's quite a disparity the disparity
though is due to the fact that bad
thoughts are not the problem in and of
themselves
right it's the combination of identity
and thought
that determines what a person is allowed
to think and say and what their fate
will be
that's what this is about
the canceled mob will will look at you
and your identity and they will decide
what you're allowed to think
and what you're allowed to say even in
private
and that will be judged
entirely based on your identity
gruden is a white man and even worse
if his comments about the anthem and
biden are any indication
he's a right-wing white man or at the
very least he's certainly not a leftist
white man
and that was his real crime
all the rest is pretense
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
um okay so you know one one other note
about that i continue to
and i know that there's that this is
this is a
a moot point because all the people in
the media at sports media
you know who are pretending to be so
scandalized oh my gosh by what by what
john gruden said in those emails
um i know that again it's pretense
they are pretending this is all
theatrical this is all performative
but taking them at face value for a
moment
i uh once again invite any of them
to
to release their to give to give the
public their gmail passwords
so that we can comb through their emails
and just and take a look and see
if at any point over the last 10 years
they have ever sent even a single
private message to a friend or a family
member where they used a vulgar
offensive language
now i said this to mark mark lamont hill
of course a well-known race spader
uh he was responding to me on twitter
where i made the point that um
as i just did in the opening that
gruden's
vulgar comments were in private emails
uh the people who received the emails
didn't care nobody else knew about them
so this is a victimless crime
and grunting is getting canceled for
thought crimes
and marklemont hill responded he said
agreed you know being sarcastic he says
i mean what are the chances that a
racist sexist and homophobic person
would do anything improper in a
leadership position and why shouldn't a
private company employ someone who has
brought shame and disgrace
libs am i right
now of course the problem with the way
that he's presenting this is first of
all
john gruden he didn't bring the nfl
shame and disgrace nobody knew about
this shame and disgrace is something
that happens in the public
in in the public's eye
the only reason the public knows about
these shameful emails is that the nfl
told them
so he did not bring shame and disgrace
to anyone
no one knew about it
um
and as far as well you know if if he's
saying these things in private then
probably he's acting improperly in his
leadership position well is he
he's been in a leadership position in
for for this organization for three
years he was a coach before that
so if he's done if he's actually done
wrong things
if he has has in fact acted improperly
in his position
then why are we just being told that
if that was the case they'd tell us that
but no by all indications
he's behaved perfectly fine
you know
these are just his private thoughts
and even though he's reserving that for
private and not publishing it
uh still he's being he's being uh
cancelled for it but even so you know i
i said to mark lyon i'm still waiting
for the response but i invited him
to uh just you know he could send it to
me or he could or he could put it out on
twitter
either way
give us your gmail
um password
and and we'll go through yeah and we'll
we'll keep it to a decade we won't look
we won't look back any farther than that
i promise uh but we'll keep it to a
decade and we'll look back a decade and
see have you ever said anything in your
private communications and you know what
show us your text messages as well while
while we're at it
do you really want to claim that
does anyone
all the people pretending to be offended
do any of them want to claim
that over the course of 10 years
they have never said anything offensive
through text message or email
at all
if you wanna you know anyone who wants
to make that claim just step up and say
so but then put your money where your
mouth is prove it let's see
all right we'll start with this now uh
this is this is one uh i'll mention kind
of briefly and and i'll probably want to
go into more detail about it tomorrow
because it's a very important story and
deserves you know more than uh
than a brief mention
but here's a report
exclusive report um
in the by the daily wire you go to
dailywire.com and find it and the
headline is
loudoun county schools tried to conceal
sexual assault against a daughter in the
bathroom
according to the daughter's father
now here's the some of the background on
this
i'll just read some from the report
it says on june 22nd scott smith was
arrested at a loudoun county virginia
school board meeting a meeting that was
ultimately deemed an unlawful assembly
after many attendees vocally opposed a
policy on transgender students
what people did not know is that weeks
prior on may 28th smith says a boy
allegedly wearing a skirt entered a
girl's bathroom at nearby stone bridge
high school where he has sexually
assaulted smith's ninth grade daughter
juvenile records are sealed but scott's
attorney elizabeth lancaster told the
daily wire that a boy was charged with
two counts of forcible sodomy one count
of anal sodomy and one count of forcible
fellatio related to an incident that day
at the school
as a result of the viral video showing
his arrest smith became the poster child
for what the national school birds
association has since suggested as
potential domestic terrorism that is a
white blue-collar male who showed up to
harangue obscure public servants on his
local school board
now there's a there's a lot more to this
story and i would again encourage you to
go to dailywire.com
and uh and read it for yourself i can't
read the entire thing here
but the the uh
the important points to note here
are that allegedly
uh a a girl was raped
in a bathroom
during school hours
in a girl's bathroom by a male
allegedly the male was wearing a skirt
at the time
now there's no indication that he
identifies as trans i believe
but that's
totally irrelevant to the point
and it's especially irrelevant to the
point that um loudoun county schools
wanted to this according to the father
uh they wanted to handle this in-house
a rape of a student they wanted to keep
that in-house
so so just right in line with the kinds
of sexual assault cover-ups that we've
seen in so many other institutions
including in the public school system
this is not the first time that this
kind of thing has happened in public
school where there's been a sexual
assault in a public school
um either you know student against
student or teacher against student and
it's certainly not the first time that a
public school has uh has said well we're
gonna handle this in-house we're gonna
why do they want to handle it in-house
well
for all of the obvious reasons including
the fact that um
while
when this happened
the school board and the school system
they were in the process of trying to
push this trans bathroom policy through
and they wanted to be able to claim
as they just went ahead and claimed
anyway
that there's been no assaults in the
bathroom at all
by males against females
which was a lie
and to make it to make all of this even
worse if if it could possibly get worse
this father who was
i mean understandably
i'm not sure i have the word to describe
what what he must
would i say furious but i think
something
something even more a word even more
severe is probably needed here
uh this this father
enraged you know he goes to the the uh
the school after this happened the
parents were contacted and they were
told that oh there was an incident
and he shows up there and they're trying
to downplay it
and he gets extremely upset and starts
you know yelling and everything like
like any father would
uh and then he shows up to the school
board meeting
when they're talking about putting a
policy in place to
officially codify this oh yeah well
let's make mixed males and females in
the restrooms because we know how well
that goes
and he gets really upset there and he's
yelling
and then he gets into some kind of minor
altercation with somebody else and he
gets arrested
and that case specifically when we when
we hear about violence at school board
meetings
there has been almost none
with rare exception and one of the rare
exceptions was this case
so the media uses this case of a of a
distraught angry father
whose daughter was raped in a bathroom
and it was covered up
reacting as any father would to that
they use that
as one of their this case without any of
the details all they're telling us is
that is this uh this man's reaction at
the school
they're using this as a justification to
label
all parents
at school board meetings including scott
smith domestic terrorists
it is it is unspeakably evil all of it
the whole story
from what the from what this guy this
this
male allegedly did
to have the way the school handled it
and the school board
knowing what happened
to this uh man's daughter
they still pushed this policy through
and why do they push it through because
they don't give a damn
about the safety of kids
you really got to understand if you're
sending your kids to public school
this is not hyperbole the people running
these schools they do not care
about your child's safety they don't
care
do you think any of the people on this
school board lost any after pushing a
policy through
to put males in into female lockers when
we when we know
allegedly
that at least one girl had been raped
recently you think they lost any sleep
over it you think they're worried at all
you think they care in the slightest no
all they care about is the ideological
agenda that's all they care about
people are just pawns your children are
pawns to them
these people are scum the lowest of the
low
running school board meetings
and what do they do after that
the loudoun county school board what do
they do after this
after this incident
um that's when they basically shut down
the meetings
they don't let the public inside
and you're only given 60 seconds to
speak
how convenient for them how convenient
right that uh that they just had to put
these policies in place for safety
right after this incident happened
which means coincidentally now you're
not going to get an angry crowd of
people in the room
talking about this alleged rape
they're not going to have a lot of time
to speak about it
i believe when i went to the loudoun
county meeting
one of the people to go before me did
mention this case but they only had 60
seconds and they got cut off like
mid-sentence
absolute scum i mean really
and does does all of this relate back
does it really relate back to the trans
bathroom issue
if this kid uh allegedly doesn't
identify as trans or i don't know what
he identifies as
um
if that's the case does it still relate
back to the trans bat bathroom issue yes
yes it does
the school system obviously thinks it
does
which is why they tried to cover this up
it relates back for a few reasons but
we'll start with this
because it demonstrates
to anybody who needed
you know uh to have this demonstrated to
them
why you don't mix
boys and girls
in high school bathrooms and locker
rooms
is why you don't mix them
bad things happen when you mix them
nothing good can happen
there's no possible
positive outcome
it's just a matter of how bad it will be
and we see it gets very very bad
all right so southwest uh we'll mention
this as well briefly southwest
their
flight cancellations continue as they
continue to uh to claim that this has
nothing to do with the pilot strike even
though pilots went on strike over the
vaccine mandate and then right after
that they're canceling flights by the
thousands
and there's chaos in airports all across
the country but they still say no
connection at all the ceo of southwest
was on abc
and he continued to
do a little cya dance and here's what he
said
i know spirit airlines had some trouble
as well but it seems like southwest
really bore the brunt of this why why
southwest
well i think it's about what i said i
think over half of our fleet touches the
state of florida we have a linear route
system we're just different and you know
i can't really speak to
what their issues were or weren't
everyone was impacted on friday
and everyone was impacted in a very big
way seeing a lot of people invested in
this idea that this is somehow related
to vaccine mandates
there's just no evidence of that you
know as i said and as captain murray
said our people are working very hard
they're doing a great job i'm very proud
of them
and especially when we get into a
difficult situation like this
they're also delayed they're also ending
up in places
that they didn't expect so
now our people are doing a phenomenal
job
and the vaccine mandate obviously is
controversial and it's not anything that
that i wish for our company this is a
government mandate it's a presidential
order
and we're doing our best to comply with
that according to the deadlines that
have been set
we're not going to fire any employees
over this we're urging all of our
employees to get vaccinated if they
can't get vaccinated
we're urging them to seek an
accommodation so
you know we'll do everything we can to
support our people here
to seek an accommodation what exactly
does that mean
because the policy says that there
really are no accommodations
you have to get vaccinated
so this to me seems to be
just a bald-faced lie
uh which is the
and this is the narrative that
southwest has settled on and we know
this is how lies work they have a
snowball effect
when you tell the first lie then you
gotta tell another lie you gotta keep
lying
and then you get to a point where now
you definitely can't tell the truth
because
now you'd be confessing not just to one
lie but to a thousand lies all the other
lies that you told because of the one
lie
and so they decided at the very
beginning to not be honest about why
this was happening
uh that's what they're gonna stick to
but it it defies all common sense
that there would be no relation
whatsoever
you know he uses the excuse you heard i
think some of it there in the clip but
in a longer interview
he says that a lot of this goes back to
florida and there were some air traffic
control you know it was grounding
flights in florida it was weather
related and everything
but that doesn't get around the fact
that no other airline
was cancelling you know it was like in
terms of cancellations
delta versus southwest it was something
like three to
fifteen hundred
in a day
um
i don't know is is this
are southwest planes
especially susceptible to
bad weather
is that the case because if that's the
case then please tell me that so i can
keep take that into account the next
time i'm uh deciding what airline to
take when i got to fly somewhere
or or maybe you know maybe this is a
weather phenomenon
that is that only targets southwest
planes
it's a very unique phenomenon but this
does happen sometimes
it could be a giant tornado or something
that kind of chooses
based on the color of the plane i don't
know
now it's science
so that's possible or this is all total
complete nonsense
from people who have no problem lying to
you just like the loudoun county school
board they're all cut from the same
cloth they have no problem lying to you
for two reasons number one they think
that uh it's it's it's for the best
you know ends justify the means
and for the loudoun county school board
the the end was pushing the transgender
bathroom policy for this it's pushing
vaccine mandates
and when your
ideology is grounded in moral relativism
then this is what you're going to
ascribe to this idea that ends justify
the means
and if the means are simply lying well
who cares about that
and they'll go much further than lying
if they need to
so that's one reason the other reason is
that they simply don't believe that you
are owed the truth
you as some peon
some mere passenger some mere customer
some mere parent on a school board
you're not owed the truth they don't owe
it to you
all right let's move now to this uh
going back to the sports world
unfortunately greg popovich is the head
coach of the spurs and for some reason
he uh
had some thoughts about
columbus day
that he wanted to share while he's you
know i mean
you think we want to talk to him about
basketball that's really his only area
of expertise but he wanted to talk about
columbus day too and uh this is what he
had to say
i'm a little confused about
our city
and why it's indigenous people's day
slash columbus day
columbus
i mean he initiated
a new world genocide
that's what he did
and
beginning with him
and what he said in motion what followed
meant
the annihilation of every indigenous
person in hispaniola which was haiti and
the dominican republic today that's what
he did
he took slaves
uh he he mutilated he murdered
uh
and
we're gonna they're gonna say slash and
honor him
well you know i'm gonna give the san
antonio independent school district a
little bit of credit because at least
they added indigenous people's day along
with it and that's a step in the right
direction but what the hell is alamo
heights thinking
it's columbus day that's why they're off
on monday
you know maybe there's something i'm
missing and i'm ignorant
but it makes me feel like they're living
in a phone booth and they're educating
our kids
columbus day
and we're going to honor that
and it's it's it's no knock on italian
americans that's a silly argument
you know it's like saying we should be
proud of hitler because we're german
maybe there's something you're missing
uh yeah i think there is like a comb for
one
is that actually the head coach of the
spurs or is that a homeless guy who just
stumbled out of the methadone clinic
down the street i'm not exactly sure
um
but you see a couple things happening
here
number one he's he said columbus state
you're celebrating columbus day
this is unthinkable
he's reacting that way to
something that
up until 10 seconds ago
everybody celebrated columbus day
you know he's by the looks of it 97 or
98 years old
and so he's been living in a country for
nearly a century that celebrates
columbus day
and as far as i know he's he's it hasn't
been ranting about it all that entire
time
and and now so
but this is what they do
you know they want to make a drastic
change
and this is a very drastic change it's
not just about the holiday
but rather than celebrating columbus and
the european settlers and pioneers who
came here and brought civilization to
these shores and are are you know among
the founders of the civilization that we
currently live in rather than
celebrating them we're not going to
celebrate them anymore
we're going to celebrate the indigenous
people even though as i reviewed
yesterday
no one has really explained what exactly
we're celebrating about these indigenous
people what are we celebrating
but wherever you fall on that this is a
drastic change in our culture
uh only the left and he's a member of
the left
they'll never really admit that they're
proposing a
a change at all let alone a drastic
change
we're doing something a certain way
for years and years and decades
and then they come along and say um you
know what uh no we're going to do it
this other way now
and the moment they say that the moment
they say it
if you do not
go along with them and make this sudden
left turn
then you're not just wrong i mean
they're not they're not going to simply
argue with you and try to
try to present present
justifications for this change they're
going to treat you like a lunatic
you're doing what people have have
always done for years
and they're proposing a whole new thing
but if you simply stay on that same path
that you've already been on
and that they themselves were on up
until that moment
now you're insane it's like it's it's
they treat it as
self-evidently
absurd
that's the game they always play and
it's very effective
people fall for it
because when you when you propose a
drastic change and you admit that it's a
drastic change
people tend to evaluate that a little
bit differently they say oh well drastic
change i don't know if i don't know if
i'm really game for that let's let's
talk about it
but when you when you act as though your
new proposed path is well clearly we
should be doing this instead
putting putting that pretense on it it's
very effective in
convincing people or if not convincing
them then shaming them into scaring them
into silence
and of course he makes the comparison
between columbus and hitler
uh which is the same comparison that
you know any
high school junior
uh
will make
based on you know reading three
sentences about about columbus
this is uh part of this goes goes back
to a
absolute historical illiteracy on the
part of many people in this country
yeah
you go up to the average especially the
average leftist who wants to
throw columbus into the burn pile
ask them to to just start listing
historical figures as many as they can
name they could probably give you like
five
and they're going to have those
historical figures separated
a clear line between them black and
white
you've got the bad guys and the good
guys
and hitler he's like the main bad guy
and anyone who's on his side is
basically hitler throw columbus in there
that's the way they look at it
no understanding of history whatsoever
a fa i would say it's a failure of the
public school system but it's not really
a failure because it's they're doing
exactly what they intend to do
they don't want to give students a real
appreciation for history or for
historical context
least of all do they want students to
graduate with any sort of admiration
for um
any of the men who used to be the heroes
considered the heroes of our
civilization
uh
genocide
well we already know that that uh the
europeans they did not bring slavery to
the americas that was already here
they didn't bring conquest that was
already here
they didn't bring any they didn't bring
any of those things
did they bring genocide no they didn't
i mean archaeologists are still digging
up
mass graves
um of uh of various indian tribes
from pre-contact times like hundreds of
years before any european
ever showed up here
there were entire tribes
being wiped out
who was responsible for that
was it the europeans were they sneaking
over here unbeknownst to anybody
so they didn't bring that either
um
and as far as celebrity you know the
thing is in other countries
columbus is not a villain despite how
he's how he's portrayed
but there are countries in this world
non-western countries
that without any embarrassment
will celebrate truly villainous historic
figures
because those historical figures are
you know the founders of their of their
culture
genghis khan for example i mean there
are there are statues to genghis khan in
mongolia
genghis khan who
was such a prolific rapist
that you know
whatever a third of the world is related
to him right now
whatever the number is
i mean this is a guy who who who
is responsible for the slaughter of
millions of people
without using bombs or guns
and they have no shame about it no
embarrassment whatsoever
that's who genghis khan was but
he's their founder he's their historical
hero and they honor him
columbus was not genghis khan not even
close
but in the west we're the only ones who
have this kind of embarrassment of our
of ours about our historical figures
let's see one other quick uh
note here
it says from the daily wire it says
california governor gavin newsom on
tuesday signed a bill to streamline the
assisted suicide process for terminally
ill patients who wish to end their own
lives the bill will slash the current
15-day waiting period for patients to
get the legal drugs to a mere 48 hours
the law also requires health care
providers to post their
physician-assisted suicide policies on
their websites
so they already had uh assisted suicide
but gavin knew some he looked at it and
he said you know the real problem here
is that people aren't able to kill
themselves quickly enough
just think about that for a second the
15-day waiting period but to have
assisted suicide at all is barbaric
but with a 15-day waiting period the
point is you're giving people some more
time to think about what they're about
to do because you're making a choice you
cannot take back
and gavin newsom is saying no give them
less time to think about it
what could possibly be
the non-horrifying reason for that
oh you just want to get you want these
people gone
all right you're done let's just get you
out of here let's get let's get you off
of the earth
that's the attitude
and there
we don't have time to get into all the
problems with assisted suicide
assisted suicide which is in and of
itself is kind of a euphemism
um
but maybe we shouldn't have to go any uh
beyond this point
that this is a total inversion
of medicine
and a corruption and perversion of the
medical profession
you know doctors traditionally in
hippocratic oath are swearing to do no
harm
and whether they take any official oath
or not that is that's supposed to be the
idea behind medicine it is to treat
and cure and heal
um destroying a life is not treating it
it's certainly not curing or healing it
you you don't treat someone's body by
destroying it by poisoning it
and so you have turned medicine on its
head when doctors become dealers of
death
and yet of course even without assisted
suicide we know that that's already the
case all across the country because
that's what abortionists do who call
themselves doctors
but it is not a positive trend
you know to have a doctor
in one room
he's got a patient with cancer and that
then that patient wants to wants to
stick around and fight it
and so he's trying to help that uh that
person overcome and try to treat their
their illness
then he goes over to the next room
and he's helping that person kill
themselves
to have this kind of schizophrenic
approach to medicine is uh not a
positive development at all all right
let's get to our uh
youtube comments
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is from lieutenant crazy man says
matt you're a genuine imbecile angry and
childish i listen to arguments from you
but it hurts my brain trying to decipher
the flatulence that comes from your
mouth
uh
i don't know if this is supposed to be a
joke because you spelled imbecile
i-m-b-a-c-i-l-e
in-day cell
matt you're damned in bsl
uh and i'll i will never you know that's
that's always going to be hilarious to
me when someone tries to call you stupid
and misspells it in the process so thank
you for that i i you know i'm going to
give you the benefit of the doubt and
say this was a joke on your part
uh
nicholas the cage says
you don't like dogs and flying makes you
anxious matt if you didn't have kids i'd
wonder if you were even a man
i know i think uh disliking
flying that's uh that's quite
i have a manly reason for it the reason
i don't like flying the anxiety comes
from the lack of control
that's why i have no anxiety about
driving even though statistically we all
know driving is significantly more
dangerous i mean you're way more likely
to die in the car
uh than you are on a plane being on a
plane 35 000 feet in the air
is
probably the safest place on earth
and it's not even you know on
earth on the earth on the ground anyway
and i recognize all that
but
i i still don't feel like i have control
and that's where the anxiety comes from
i need it's my desire for control
um
let's see jack says on the topic of
indigenous people's day it really says
something about our cultural decay that
we choose to celebrate the conquered
rather than the conquerors
a good microcosm for the victimhood
culture that plagues our society yeah it
is it is kind of interesting one of the
things that we always hear is that uh
when it comes to tearing down the
confederate statues
the people who support that
what's one of the things they always say
they always say that well we why are we
celebrating losers they're the loser
they lost the war
well
in this
in the indian war in the battle of
civilizations the indigenous people lost
could you apply that same logic
there um
david oswald says it should be called
vikings day it was my ancestors who
landed first a millennia before columbus
yeah yeah of course we hear about leif
erickson and everything but the the and
okay but
he didn't establish
lasting colonies in the new world
so it didn't have the same history
shaping
um civilization changing
effect
it's i still still quite i mean i'm
impressed with anyone
back in in history
able to get on a ship
without any modern navigational
equipment whatsoever
and go from point a to point b and not
die in the process i'm impressed by all
of that personally
but there is a significant difference
um
and finally another comment says very
few natives were violent to each other
isn't the whole thing with native
american tribes was the fact that they
didn't own the land the land owns them
you want to talk about painting a bra a
large brush you hypocrite
hypocrites spelled
h-i-p-p-c-r-i-t-e hip-crit
you hypocrite
you in-base sale hypocrite
uh this is another one that i i i want
to think is a joke
i mean i guess i don't want to believe
that there are people this dense
actually watching my show that would
make me question myself
very few native tribes were violent to
each other really
they were all violent to each other
but it's not just them
violence was the way of the world
for thousands of years through human
civilization
our ancestors were brutal people and
when i say our ancestors i mean
everybody i don't care what the color of
your skin is or where you're from
and you know something else
if you lived
500 years ago or a thousand years ago
you would have been a brutal person too
or you'd be dead
you know you would have died those would
those really would have been your two
choices especially if you were a man
so that's the reality across the world
but uh were native american tribes
violent to each other yes they were and
what i would suggest is you know maybe
instead of getting all of your
historical information from facebook
memes maybe pick up a book
just a thought we know that abortion
advocates are going insane still over
the texas law banning abortion i mean
they already were insane but they
continue even more in that state because
of this law
and that's why we need as this
conversation continues we need as many
voices as possible to join the defense
of texas and any other states that are
joining the fight for life that's one of
the reasons why i wrote the forward to
the new book from 40 days for life what
to say when the complete new guide to
discussing abortion i wrote the forward
to it i read the book myself and found
it very useful even as someone who
argues about these issues all the time
and i feel like i know them pretty well
i still found useful tips and a lot of
other people have as well that's why
this book has been number one
on the amazon new release chart and a
number two amazon bestseller the book is
very easy to use it tells you what to
say what not to say
and also the proven arguments that have
worked for everybody they've even used
these arguments with planned parenthood
workers and they've converted 221 of
them that's how compelling it is so go
to amazon right now or get the book
directly that's what to say when the
complete new guide to discussing
abortion uh you can get it directly from
40 days for life at 40daysforlife.com
and tonight is the night it's a huge
night for backstage instead of the usual
daily wire studio we'll be live
streaming our conversation on stage at
the famous ryman auditorium right here
in nashville where we'll attempt to make
sense of the increasingly authoritarian
world we're living in this will be an
event and a live stream unlike any other
that we've done before
and you're not going to want to miss it
so join myself ben shapiro candace owens
jeremy boring michael knowles andrew
clavin and our live audience for
backstage like never before tonight's
live stream will begin at 8 30 pm
eastern 7 30 pm central so head to
dailywire.com or dailywireyoutube to
catch the show now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
so today for our daily cancellation we
must pick on some random sap who wrote a
letter seeking advice from a new york
times columnist which should give you an
idea of just how
clueless and desperate this person
really is but our purpose is not simply
to mock this person that's part of the
purpose yeah but the larger purpose is
to talk about the deeper societal issue
that this person's attitude is
symptomatic of so writing to advice
columnist roxane gay a person named brit
from indianapolis poses this quandary
brit says i am 27. in the last year i
landed my dream job my job has purpose
my skills and qualifications are used
and challenged
my co-workers and supervisors are
unparalleled but alas
40 hours a week is not sustainable i
have hobbies
i have creative pursuits and therapy and
laundry
and i own a small dog so i am busy
um
anyway my partner and i are considering
starting a family in a few years
because i already feel like there's not
enough time in the week i wonder what
getting away from the 40-hour workweek
looks like i've considered
self-employment trying out the artist
lifestyle going back into academia
mildly rejecting capitalism but maybe i
should just get over it thoughts
now the answer from roxanne dances
around the issue trying to validate this
person's concerns and perspective while
still gently suggesting that maybe just
maybe
work is an unavoidable fact of life
though she does leave open the hope that
perhaps we as a culture
will eventually decide there is indeed
more to life than work
of course saying there's more to life
than work is like saying there's more to
life than water or breathing
it's true at face value but it's not
true if what you mean
is that these things are negotiable or
expendable
you cannot have life without water or
oxygen you cannot have life without work
all people must work to live or else
they must force someone else to do the
work for them those are the only two
options
there are no other options
there will never be any others
work may not be life
but life is work
anyone telling you different is selling
you something to paraphrase the princess
pride now capitalism did not invent work
here's another history lesson
in pre-industrial times
life
was work
and also work was life and that for them
they had it both
for everyone but the privileged few
royalty nobility back in those days
every second of every day was a battle
to survive it was work
capitalism is just one system of work it
is just one way for people to exploit
their work in order to sustain
themselves
it also happens to be the best system
certainly better than any other system
that anybody has ever devised
so this is one important point you
cannot escape work
unless you escape it by living off the
work of others but then you haven't
decreased the amount of work that needs
to be done you've just pawned your share
off on someone else
and this is a bad option because it's
immoral and if you don't care about
morality maybe you'll care about this a
life without work is far more miserable
than a life of work
to be unproductive to reap the fruits of
labor that you didn't participate in to
have striving and effort and ambition
removed from your life entirely that's a
recipe for despair
check in with jackpot lottery winners
sometime and see how happy they really
are or welfare recipients or unemployed
adults who live at home with their
parents these are not joyful people
you could be satiated in a life like
that you could be numb and comfortable
but joy comes from striving
there's no other way to find it
so that's the first point the second
obviously is that 40 hours a week
is really not that much at all 40 hours
a week leaves you 16 hours a day during
the week and 48 hours on the weekend
you have 128 hours
a week to yourself to do what you want
even with a basket of laundry to fold
and a small dog to take care of still
you should have a healthy surplus of
free time i mean i can't even imagine
having that much free time it sounds
almost mythological
it is literally beyond my wildest dreams
and yet it's not enough
how much free time do you want
eight hours of work a day five days a
week is too much how many hours do you
think you ought to be doing
what 30 minutes a day is that the goal
the problem here is not just the whiny
pathetic laziness that's so endemic in
our society today but also a total
inability
to prioritize time
this is also endemic and we all
you know
suffer from this to one degree or
another
you look at any poll or any survey on
the subject or you talk to almost
anybody and you'll find that nearly
everyone thinks that they're so busy and
they complain about their stress and
their anxiety and they feel overworked
and exhausted etc
and yet we also know that americans
spend 10 hours a day on their phones
watching tv you know playing video games
cumulatively
i read one report that says that the
average american
is subscribed to four streaming services
and streams up to eight hours a day of
content
i bet the person who sent this question
to the new york times is on the higher
end of those averages so how can it be
that we waste our lives consuming media
but also we're stressed out and busy
well again because we don't know how to
prioritize our time
also most of us have terrible diets and
don't get enough exercise which
contributes to both exhaustion and
feelings of stress
we have no sense of higher purpose in
life which causes anxiety many factors
can be taken into account here but an
inability to prioritize time is
certainly a major one chances are
whatever it is you'd like to do with
your time but think you don't have time
to do
the lack of time is a figment of your
imagination it's an illusion
where does this illusion come from i
mean how have we all convinced ourselves
that we're so busy and uh and and
stressed out even as we spend a third of
the day staring at images on screens
i think the answer is threefold one
we've fooled ourselves into believing
that we're busy because we equate
busyness with importance and we want to
feel important two most of our time is
wasted consuming media and we tend to go
into a slightly catatonic state when we
consume media especially if we're in the
middle of a streaming binge which means
our perception of time is altered
social media is specifically designed to
have this effect
it's made it's made to keep you sort of
glued there while not perceiving just
how much time you're spending on it
that's what they call eternal scrolling
is all about where you just keep
scrolling and scrolling down a screen
and it never never ends
and then third there's marketing most of
the advertisement and marketing that
bombards our eyes and ears carries with
it this message that we're all a bunch
of super busy people leading busy
bustling lives
advertising companies want to sell us on
our business because they want to sell
products that are meant to help with
that fictional problem
most consumer products are focused on
making our lives easier more convenient
because you know we we need more
shortcuts because our lives are so
hectic
or else we're being sold things that are
supposed to give us rest and recreation
so that we can have a break from those
allegedly busy lives of ours
either way the marketing companies have
to first tell us that we're busy
so they can sell the cure to it not
unlike the method used by pharmaceutical
companies
and that's how we with hours and hours
of free time every day
still convince ourselves that we don't
have time to start the hobby that we
want to start or go to the gym
or read a book
or do whatever other worthwhile and
edifying thing we want to do
we're just too busy we've got our dog
and the laundry and hulu and netflix and
disney plus and apple tv
there's just no time
even though there's lots of time
i mean all we have is time
it's just a matter of how we choose to
spend it
and so that's my advice to that uh
person who sent the question to the new
york times columnist
but even after giving the advice i still
have to say to them that they are
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical directors austin stevens
production manager pablo vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle we'll tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there